do skills Trump passion recently did a
Twitter chat with LegalZoom and I was
answering question from entrepreneurs
you guys have a ton of great questions I
was typing so fast that my hands were
getting tired and at the end of the hour
I needed a break and one of the
questions was so great that I thought
I'd make a video about it to expand on
it further it came from one of our
followers Jennifer Price who wrote in
with the question do skills Trump
passion this is really important okay
because a lot of people a lot of
entrepreneurs when you're starting up
you have an idea for a business and you
may hold yourself back because you say I
really love this idea but I don't have
the skills to do it you know I didn't go
to school for that I never learned how
to do this I've never had any experience
in this field and that holds you back
from starting your business you have to
understand that the most important rule
in business is to follow your passion
it's so important no other rule in
business no other principle no other
strategy will save you if you don't love
what you're doing
you can learn any skill that's what
skills are the things that you learn and
you learn it quickly if you're
passionate and excited about it if you
go into a business just because you're
good at something you're never gonna
have success with it because you don't
love it let me give you a quick example
I recently signed up with an agency so I
have an agent and my agents out there
he's representing me for closing deals
and seminars and book deals and all this
kind of stuff so a lot of fun stuff
happening when I first spoke with him he
said I'm not quite sure what to do with
you Evan I said why and he said most of
the people who come to us are really
great on camera they've had tons of
experience on camera and doing shows and
doing presentations but they're not
quite sure what they stand for they
don't have an important message so we
work with them to hone their messaging
you're the complete opposite you have an
important message we know what you stand
for but you kind of suck in front of the
camera
like what you're killing me here I
thought I was pretty good but he was
right and I look back on my old videos
and they needed a lot of work I had this
big gap in my skill set and he said
we're gonna take you on as a client and
and we'll see what happens he'll tell
you what happened I had a goal okay my
goal is to help a billion entrepreneurs
and I realized that for that to happen I
needed to get better on camera I need to
be better with my YouTube videos and do
better when I went on TV shows and radio
shows I had to be better when I
delivered presentations and keynote
speeches I had to get better at that
skill to achieve my goal and so I
started working at it really really hard
and I got better quickly because I was
passionate about it I made a thousand
videos a thousand videos I'm launching
two videos every single day now on my
youtube channel and it's funny because
within the agency I'm now being used as
the person to look up to they point to
my channel as the best practice are you
kidding me I was the worst person a few
months ago I was the worst guy there and
it changed like that because I applied
dedication to my craft if you don't have
the skills you can learn them quickly
I quickly outpaced the people at the
agency because I'm doing two videos
every single day where they struggle to
find the time to do one per week that's
the difference when you're passionate
about something you make it important
and you learn whatever skill you need to
be successful so if you're thinking of
starting a business right now always
pick the idea that you're more
passionate about even if you don't have
the skills to make it happen yet because
you'll develop them if you're bringing
on a team you're hiring more people to
your company or maybe hiring your first
employee always hire the person who's
more excited to work at your business
because if you look at two resumes you
may find that one person has a lot more
experience and a lot more skills but if
they don't
of your business and what you stand for
and love the opportunity to come and
work for you if they're not passionate
about it they're not going to be a great
employee for you where if you picked a
guy who doesn't have as many skills but
wants to be there loves it wants to
learn to be better he or she may make a
few mistakes at the beginning but it's
always gonna be the longer-term win
passion always Trump's skills it's no
contest
so Thank You Jennifer for the question
and I was happy to be able to have the
time to expand on a little bit more for
you guys hopefully I can do another a
Twitter chat with LegalZoom soon we'll
keep you posted but I am excited to
announce that for the launch of national
start your business month LegalZoom is
creating a new website that celebrates
entrepreneurs who have hit their I did
it moment and they want to share those
stories so I'm going to include the link
in the description below I hope you guys
will check it out always remember that
passion Trump's skills and keep
believing thank you guys for watching
you liked the video give it a thumbs up
below let me know what you think in the
comments section you have a question for
your business leave in the comments
below I'm a good video response and if
you want to see more videos like this
click on my face subscribe to the
channel thanks so much and I'll see you
soon